hey guys welcome back for another video
uh still traveling here in Amsterdam so
trying to make it so I can crank out
about a video a week and stay consistent
a couple quick announcements first of
all uh By the time this one's posted uh
hopefully I'll be around 7 500
subscribers uh which if that is the case
then thank you guys a lot um I
appreciate all the nice feedback you've
been giving me all the work that you
guys are putting in if I don't have 7
500 I'll look like kind of an ass by
saying this but whatever we're close
enough another quick thing to say is I
want to give a shout out to two of my
viewers both of whom have reached out to
me in light of their recent new
positions uh both to Carl for his
position his senior engineering manager
at Google and for Roy on his offering
Microsoft these are guys who have been
commenting and interacting with the
channel for a while so to see that
payoff really does make my day sometimes
this channel doesn't get as many views
as I would like but at the end of the
day if that's really all that you care
about um I would just post Day in the
Life videos on Tick Tock and you know
systems aside so anyways let's get
into the content for today I'm gonna
whip out the iPad and get started all
right so today's video is going to be
about serializable snapshot isolation
which is a type of optimistic
concurrency control and so we're going
to talk about what that means so if you
guys watched last video which I'm hoping
you did it'll help you understand this
one a lot better what we did was we
talked about acid databases how they
tend to achieve full isolation or
serializability and in the past this has
been done with something known as
two-phase locking which is a pessimistic
concurrency control meaning that
basically every single transaction that
runs regardless of whether it impacts
other transactions has to grab locks for
all of the rows that it reads and writes
and this can be problematic because most
of the transactions like myself are
Sigma males they don't deal with other
transactions they do their own thing and
so if I'm just going to run one isolated
transaction and you know no one else is
even coming near it I don't have to
actually grab those locks I can just do
my own thing it would speed up the
database quite a bit so basically
optimistic and currency control is
asking the question well do we really
need locks effect if what's going to
happen is we can just run as normal and
if we do catch that we're about to make
a mistake we can just abort one of those
offending transactions and run it so
let's go ahead and start looking at a
couple of cases because the general gist
of this is we're reading from a snapshot
right and then once we see some read
modify update transactions that we don't
like then we're going to have to take a
little bit of extra action so let's look
at case one there are two cases here and
this is where SSI is going to come in so
in the first case let's imagine we have
a database snapshot at t18 so the first
thing I should say is a snapshot is just
a consistent state of a database at some
point in time in this case it would be
after transaction 18 was committed if
you want to know more about snapshot
isolation I already made a video on it
probably three or four ago so I'd
recommend watching that if you're a
little unsure what I mean here
so let's imagine we have some database
table where you know we've got a couple
of uh women and whether they like Jordan
or not obviously most of the rows are
going to be true but we'll talk about
how that changes throughout the example
so first we've got Kate Upton
and she obviously likes Jordan as one
does however t19 is coming in and t19 is
going to change that field from True to
false but as we know with transactions
first at least for All rights they're
going to be uncommitted and then
eventually they're going to commit so
there's this little bit of time where we
can see that a write exists but it
hasn't necessarily gone through yet
meaning we can't read it because if we
could read uncommitted rights I believe
if I'm remembering correctly that's a
dirty read so
let's go ahead and look at kind of the
the time by time things that's going to
happen so the first thing is transaction
19 is going to say Kate Upton no longer
likes Jordan maybe she saw me busting
out some moves on the Dance Floor I gave
her the ick who knows doesn't really
matter at time 20 I'm coming along and I
see that Kate Upton likes me obviously I
want to send her a DM at the same time
though I also see an uncommitted right
and I say to myself hmm well it looks
like there's a chance that she might not
like me but it hasn't committed yet so
I'm not sure I'm still going to go ahead
and try and add her to my DMs table
so at right after that at the third time
stamp t19 is now going to commit and so
when I eventually go ahead and try to
send that DM I'm going to say to myself
hmm I remember there was an uncommitted
piece of write data I should probably
check whether that's committed or not
just so that I don't look like a fool by
sending a girl who doesn't like me a DM
and so what I'll see now when I actually
go and check that out is that the
committed right has actually gone
through or rather the uncommitted right
has actually gone through and what this
means for me is that I need to aboard my
transaction it's no longer valid this
uncommitted piece of data that I knew
existed but didn't want to act on just
yet actually went through unfortunately
I've got to restart my transaction and
this time around I'll be sending
karenicopt a DM instead
okay so let's look at case number two
case number two is very similar to case
number one and obviously to to be
consistent I've kept the same example
with Kate Upton and karinikov who both
like me so let's imagine now that at t18
the database looks the same again both
Kate Upton likes Jordan and Karina Kopp
likes Jordan
and so I'm really feeling spicy today
I'm gonna send her three DMS and all of
those DMS are predicated on the fact
that Kate Upton still likes me and those
DMS are going to be t19 T20 and t21
right uh you know if she still likes me
I'm gonna say hey what's up how you
doing
who knows let's not get into the
specifics of Riz here leave that to
other content creators anyways so now we
have three transactions that have read
this value right here and they haven't
yet committed because the the
corresponding right has not yet been set
so we have to check if the predicate is
still valid so right now every single
time uh we're gonna first say okay well
we've all read this row there aren't
actually any uncommitted rights on this
so in theory we're looking good but we
know that the value can still change
between my read and my right so what we
have to do here is this piece
the row itself once it's being read in a
transaction is going to keep track of
all those in progress transactions that
have yet to complete so t19 T20 and t21
are not yet done until they send a
corresponding right by virtue of putting
a row in the DMS table so now what's
going to happen at t22 is a new
transaction entirely comes along Kate
Upton decides you know what I don't like
Jordan anymore sucks to suck this is
very similar to what happens to me in
real life so as you can see now Kate
Upton has been written and that right
has both been you know uncommitted and
also committed so when I say write I
mean that the right actually went
through and it's been committed so
what's useful now is the the row itself
is actually keeping track of all of the
transactions that were depending on it
so when this value goes to false we now
need to go right over here and abort all
three of these transactions so as you
can see we're aborting t19 T20 and t21
and we can retry those eventually and
just make sure are the same conditions
apply
and see what actually happens so by
virtue of not actually grabbing locks
we're able to achieve isolation but you
know it's not always necessarily the
best thing to do so let's quickly look
at a conclusion SSI is a really great up
and coming technology but it's only
really good when most the transactions
aren't getting in the way of each other
let's say we were to have like I don't
know a distributed counter or something
where every single transaction needs to
read the counter and then increment it
by one SSI isn't going to work well
because then every single one of the
transactions is going to eventually have
to be aborted and restarted because
there are so many conflicts in that case
we would want to be using two-phase
locking so if we're thinking okay well
you know most of the transactions are
probably going to be creating race
conditions or concurrency bugs with each
other we should stick to a pessimistic
concurrency control method such as
two-phase locking but in the majority of
cases actually a lot of rights are
disjoint and don't really affect one
another if I'm going on Facebook and I'm
posting to my profile in your post
listening to your profile our rights
probably aren't impacting each other you
know that being said if two computers at
the same time are logged into my profile
and writing that could be a problem but
that's exactly what optimistic
concurrency control is able to handle in
that Minority case it's actually able to
go ahead and fix those race conditions
so I hope you guys enjoyed this video
and I will be seeing you in the next one
definitely had to avoid making a lot of
abortion jokes throughout this but I did
my best and have a good one guys